the Joe Rogan experience would you say
Jim with the green lamp thing where you
wanted to buy green light the Trump -
Hotel in the mill yes I'm not gonna do
this come on
and I know first of all the buying the
green lamp thing is a great move if
global warming is real if that becomes a
part of the United States then you can
go up there you don't have to worry
about it yeah well they say I think that
they want rights not just not to
Greenland but also there's a movement in
the arc right there they wanna do this
degree man come on that [ __ ] is
hilarious it is pretty funny you gotta
click on it though Jamie's saying yeah
it couldn't but Joe they want to do like
oil Italy now some say [ __ ] in that
photo you have you know Twitter is the
only give you like 3/4 of the picture
yeah they want to do oil drilling mm-hmm
yeah but I mean just the whole global
warming is terrifying to me the whole
climate change thing is terrifying to me
but what's more terrifying I think than
anything that is a hilarious but is that
it's funny what's more terrifying than
anything is that we some people are
resisting it and it's become politicized
and some people are just buying whole
hog into anything that gets said that
supports climate change or supports the
concept of climate change and that we've
gotten into this thing where it's an
ideologically based sort of subject ok
can I try to frame it in a way that I
hope I can convince some conservatives
watching this yes because I would love
to have the chance to do that so what I
would say to them is first of all
there's a lot of issues that you care
about that this will impact so there was
a report that came out about a year ago
which found that basically large swaths
of the Middle East will be uninhabitable
at a certain point because it would just
be too hot for human beings to live
there well we're talking about that
yesterday they have Saudi Arabian summer
where a lot of people from Saudi Arabia
come over to LA during the summer
because our summer ain't [ __ ] compared
desires so and that's the thing is you
think there's a refugee crisis when it
comes to what's happening in South
America you think there's a refugee
crisis in Europe when it came to what
happened in Syria and Iraq you ain't
seen nothing yet
right so if you're somebody who fancies
yourself against immigration or a hard
on immigration or against helping
refugees or whatever it might be just
think about what happens when you
multiply what's happening now by a
thousand okay because that's what's
going to happen at some point it's just
a matter of when and the other point I
would make to them is this people like
to you know make fun of the green New
Deal and try to pick it apart if we talk
about the green New Deal and only define
it as basically a new New Deal so the
New Deal
FDR you know put that into place this
was tried to try to fight back against
the Great Depression try to get people
employed try to fix the country right
and FDR kept getting re-elected because
FDR was beloved by the entire country
because he was fighting for regular
working people that was his thing and
that's when the Republicans like geez we
really should have term limits because
we can't beat this guy what if when we
talk about the green New Deal we're
highlighting the fact that yes we're
gonna move towards renewable and green
technology yes that's going to be a
large part of what we're doing but the
whole point guys is millions and
millions of jobs created for regular
people the whole point is to improve
this country to fix this country to try
to make it so that our infrastructure is
better than the rest of the world what
if instead of looking at this is like oh
my god
this is gonna be such a drain on the
economy and what's gonna happen to the
deficit how about you look at this like
an economic opportunity because what's
gonna happen in the future Joe there's
inevitable patents that are waiting to
be had for all these green and renewable
technologies we could lead the world on
that front or we could lag behind Russia
we could lag behind China we can lag
behind everybody else and be stuck in
you know what would effectively be a
Stone Age so they encouraged this
industry to flourish well be subsidies
like how do you what do you do to get
these industries to innovate and to pump
a shitload of money into green
technology it has to do with government
contracts it has to do with I mean first
and foremost before we even do the right
thing you have to stop doing the wrong
thing which is stop giving four billion
dollars a year every year as a subsidy
to ExxonMobil and they hilariously say
oh they need this money because it's for
research and development no it's not
they don't need it for research in
developing there are the most profitable
corporations on the planet they could do
their own research and development right
so stop subsidizing fossil fuels and
then yes what we need to do is invest in
a variety of different things that show
a little bit of promise some things
won't work
okay some things will work and then we
move forward from there and so that's
where you could get the Hyperloop all
around this country what if all this
stuff was built and brought about
because we did a massive investment in a
green new deal mm-hmm
then everybody would talk about how it's
a wonderful thing and how we're finally
leading the world and in our rightful
place I find hilarious that you know
guys like Trump and guys like Joe Biden
by the way loved to say like there's
nothing this country can't do and then
in the next sentence they go on to tell
you a thousand things that they think we
can't do and that we shouldn't do we
shouldn't even try well what what
technologies have you heard if any that
are being even proposed to mitigate
global warming or climate change well
they're anything there's the classic
ones that I think are more effective
than people give it credit for like
solar is ones that's it's effective that
people I don't think it gets its due but
then there's other things like thorium
now let me just say I'm not I'm not
talking about a thorium carks there was
a car that was proposed and apparently
was total [ __ ] they could make a
thorium car work but with north thorium
thorium is basically the way it's been
described to me is nuclear energy
without the downside of like you kick it
could melt down and destroy everything
that's been described to me so a nuclear
powered car no not a car we're talking
about power for the energy not why not a
nuclear power well the thorium story
that everybody got pissed over was
because they were trying to make it seem
like he was right around the corner or
they had the plans and it just wasn't
and those people were full of [ __ ] but
that doesn't mean thorium is bad and
totally off the table it just means that
that specific car they were talking
about was nonsense okay but if you have
thorium reactors it's basically like
meltdown proof or a nuclear facility
that's how it's been described now I'm
an idiot
I have no idea how far off we are from
actually developing that but I do know
that we need to invest in this and other
things that show potential I mean that's
the only way to move forward
[Applause]